reports allege the feud between Debra
Messing and Megan Mullally have led to
the show's cancellation the room of war
between the two sitcom stars may have
started earlier this summer when Debra
posted this image urging Emmy voters to
support Will & Grace she apparently
tagged everyone except Megan it soon
after fans noticed Megan unfollowed
Debra on Instagram and vice-versa I
don't need you we're just then this
happened this week Megan reportedly
posted a mysterious message about people
who aren't good for you and also posted
and later deleted and hence the story
about feeling the best after she lost
her attachment to somebody and just
yesterday Deborah posted this quote may
this day be the day to lead us to peace
to happiness and to joy last season
Deborah posted this playful video of the
longtime friends for ten seasons the
Will & Grace set has been a drama-free
zone
Megan shared with us even when they were
off during summer breaks the cast stayed
tight we always talk we don't
necessarily all get together but we
always are talking keeping in touch
sources tell et that there was no sign
of friction between the women when they
previously worked together on the show
and last night both women seemed happy
on set together Deborah even placing her
arm around Megan during a taping for the
sitcoms final 11th season
[Music]